in this video we'll mention an
alternative to maximum likelihood
training of conditional random fields
known as sort of likelihood so we've
seen in the previous video that we could
get an expression for the negative log
likelihood gradients with respect to the
parameters which allows us to then you
know get away an expression to compute
for performing gradient descent and
perform minimize the negative log
likelihood so perform maximum likelihood
training of our conditional random field
however it did involve an expectation
over the label or the target vector Y
and while it might only involve a few
variables it still requires performing
an inference of what the marginal
distribution over the subset of labels
that are involved in the gradient might
be so we have to perform that inference
and unless we have a graph which is
linear chain or a tree this this
approximate inference so estimating this
marginal Diskin ditional distribution
it's just an approximation it might
actually be very bad in practice so some
people have explored instead an
alternative which is to just do without
maximum likelihood training and just
change the last function to be used for
training the conditional random field I
just want to mention one such approach
which is known as pseudo likelihood so
the idea is that instead of trying to
maximize the probability of the whole Y
vector given the input we might want to
maximize instead each of the conditional
of each YK given everything else so all
otherwise and the input so one
specifically will minimize the negative
sum of the log of the probability of the
true label at position K given all other
labels at position 1 up to K minus 1
then k plus 1 up to capital K so you can
think of it as try to
in turn each YK not just from X but from
all other elements in the vector Y
what's nice is that for this expression
we can usually tractive lis compute the
exact gradients for optimizing that
objective so and that's because each of
these conditionals essentially just
require that we normalize over all
values of Y k and usually y ki will take
a fairly small number of values so it's
going to be similar to performing a
regular softmax computation and a
regular neural network though now this
probability will be influenced not just
by the input but also by other label
values and the other label values are
actually going to be the true label
values in the target vector and another
thing that's nice is that each of these
conditionals for the conditional random
field is typically only really gonna
depend on a few of the other target
variables and that's because of the
local markov property of a conditional
random field if we look at its markup
network then we know that the property
of YK given everything else reduces to
the property of YK given only its
neighbors so it's actually going to be a
much simpler expression than just this
depending on the graph structure on the
mark of network so that being said with
still to make prediction we would still
normally need to compute the marginal
distribution which might still be
intractable so it makes training more
tractable but at test time we'll make a
prediction if you wanna use prediction
based on the marginals we still have to
do some approximate inference so that
doesn't entirely solve our problem so
notice that the reason we have to do
this and that this isn't a problem here
is that here we are conditioning on the
true labels so we don't have to infer
what the other labels might be we
actually know them at training time so
we exploiting that at training time but
at test time we can't and I should say
that in practice we often find that
pseudo likelihood
works less well so it gives models are
not as good as models that are trained
by maximum likelihood
and there's some theory for backing up
why we should observe this so we're not
necessarily suggests someone uses sort
of likelihood except perhaps on a very
very complicated model but it's good to
know that there are alternatives to
conditional random fields then training
them by maximum likelihood and certain
alternatives will be sort of nicer in
terms of the computations that are
required for for training them and
training conditional random fields in
general is a very active field of
research but with all we've seen and the
this video and the previous ones that
should give you a head start for looking
at that literature more